I want to start tonight with you I know
people are worried confused
exasperated sometimes all in the same
moment and there's a curious divergence
between the real world and the people on
TV and Twitter on TV you see facts and
responsible reporting and important
helpful advice to be sure but also too
often unhelpful overdramatizing
the thinnest of veneers separates us
from chaos the number of people who are
going to be diagnosed with corona virus
is going to explode it's going to cause
is going to cause chaos is going to
cause pandemonium yet every single
person I've spoken to in the real world
including doctors academics
businesspeople that truly exasperated
they talk about a massive overreaction
it's insane is a common refrain now I
don't agree with that but I understand
why you might be thinking that it's
because there's something missing in
what we are being told by our public
health officials here's what they have
told us one most people are not at
serious risk from the corona virus while
anyone can get it and anyone can spread
it so far only a very small proportion
end up sick enough to be hospitalized
for the most part the people who get in
trouble and ultimately tragically would
die from this are people who are elderly
and/or have underlying conditions heart
disease chronic lung disease diabetes
obesity because of the difficulty in
breathing back and forth they're also
saying thankfully the kids don't get
sick from it so here's the question many
are asking if kids don't get it if most
of the people who do get it will be fine
why are we closing down America to fight
it let me try to explain why not so
we've been given is that it's the death
rate here's what dr. Fauci said to Sean
Hannity this week it's 10 times more
lethal than the seasonal flu you got to
make sure that people understand that
okay but the question is how does that
square with the other things the medics
have told us look what Ted Cruz said the
CDC told him last week prompting his
self quarantine
testing is not effective before symptoms
manifests we've also been told by the
public health officials that many
infected people won't have symptoms at
all our experience today though is that
most people more than 85% will have
milder nose symptoms so even if we get
every single American tested according
to the CDC we won't know who has
coronavirus and so an accurate death
rate is literally unknowable so it seems
to me that they're really important
number and the really important point we
all need to understand is the total
number of Americans who may need
hospital treatment at any one time
Congress's in-house doctor told
congressional staffers that he expects
70 to 150 million people in the u.s. to
contract the virus now that sounds
plausible because we know that this
virus is more contagious than normal flu
which has infected up to 90 million
people in America in a bad year we've
got about nine hundred and twenty
thousand hospital beds with most of them
already in use one estimate by an
infectious disease specialist projected
96 million infections in the US with 5%
needing hospitalization or 4.8 million
people if even a fraction of that number
is concentrated at one point in time it
would totally overwhelm our hospital
system and you end up with patients
dying in corridors like in Italy so we
have to reduce the number of
hospitalizations at any one time spread
it out in the jargon flatten the curve
that's the stated reason for school
closures and the NBA NHL and MLB and all
the rest large gatherings spread the
infection and even if there are no
vulnerable people there healthy people
can leave and infect someone who really
is at risk who then might need hospital
treatment
the idea behind closing schools is not
to protect the kids who will likely be
fine but to protect grandparents from
the kids but again many people hear all
this from the public health officials
and are asking does that really add up
you told me most people will be fine and
you told me kids don't get it
if you close schools weren't kids be
more likely to come into contact with
grandparents especially if the family
can't afford or arrange childcare so I
have a plea to dr. Falchi and the others
you want all Americans to cooperate with
your public health strategy at the
organizational level with the NBA and so
on that is happening but there are still
millions of Americans who quite frankly
don't buy into what you're saying and
simply repeating it won't work you need
to answer the big question many
Americans are asking and it's this
instead of closing schools colleges
sports and other large gatherings for
their general population why don't we
isolate the vulnerable population like
California just announced instead of
draconian steps that will tank the
economy for everyone why don't we focus
our draconian action on those most at
risk now I'm sure there's a good answer
to that question but we haven't heard it
yet from dr. Falchi or any of them and
until we do frankly you're gonna have
millions of Americans not trusting what
the officials say and that is the last
thing we need at a time of national
emergency still in the words of a
British government official I used to
work with wah wah we are where we are
the president should understand the new
reality and the new political reality
the balance has tipped from the biggest
political risk being a crashed economy
to it being the perception that
President Trump mishandled the crisis
now of course the anti-trump cult will
say he has whatever he does a public
health crisis the government has
entirely failed the President of the
United States doesn't care about us he
doesn't care about us he doesn't care
about the public you know you just look
at all of his statements and it's almost
as if Donald Trump is actively working
to tank the stock market everybody in
America knows his president lies that he
lies about things that matter and he lie
about things that don't matter but now
we have a crisis and they know he's
lying they're the ones lying the
president did act boldly restricting
travel from China the epicenter of it
all then Europe the new epicenter
helping nursing homes protect themselves
from outbreaks signing an eight point
three billion dollar aid package working
with insurance companies to cover
testing cost providing aid to small
businesses and of course the emergency
declaration which will unlock more
funding and unleash the hospital system
and national emergency services we'll
have more on the economic impact and
that testing Fiasco later tonight but
even Gavin Newsom praised the
president's actions I had a private
conversation with him around 4:30 West
Coast time and he said everything that I
could have hoped for and we had a very
long conversation and every single thing
he said they followed through on right
this is now a national emergency so the
question is what to do next and I've got
two big recommendations first our
medical capacity if there's chaos in the
hospitals like in Italy President Trump
can say goodbye to a second term the
world will be watching
don't let America's hospitals become the
equivalent of California's homeless
crisis let's set a target half a million
extra emergency hospital beds by the end
of April get them in hotels they could
use the business get FEMA in get the
military in start building now build
hospitals build clinics Trump's a
builder he can get it done get the
protective gear and respirators and ICUs
and ventilators get ahead of the demand
doctor foul she says we have 12,000 700
ventilators in the stockpile but we may
need hundreds of thousands seam of
Verma's dissembling when asked if we're
ready shows that we're not ready if we
were she'd say so get the private sector
and get the geniuses in Silicon Valley
to stop working on travel to Mars or
whatever and get them to figure out a
quick cheap way to provide respiratory
care mr.
president go to Silicon Valley and
inspire them to respond on these giant
challenges second recommendation
repatriate American manufacturing
especially medical manufacturing
starting now our dependence on China is
a national security risk I've been
saying it Donald Trump's been saying it
for decades apparently the president is
working on an executive order on this
and that is great news it should include
a formal policy of industrial
repatriation announce a list of key
strategic production that must be
located in America including essential
pharmaceuticals and announce a formal
decoupling from China we can trade with
them sure but we can't be dependent on
them for anything the era of
globalization is over America needs to
be able to rely on American
manufacturing alone to foreign companies
if you want to sell it in America you
have to make it in America it's as
simple as that one more thought I'll
leave you with I felt incredibly proud
on Friday watching that Rose Garden
press conference and incredibly lucky to
be here look how this country is
responding the private sector state and
local government individuals looking out
for each other in their communities this
is America standing up to this new
unseen enemy in a uniquely American
bottom-up grassroots way this is not the
land of top-down authoritarian dictate
this is not the home of puny vacillation
this is the land of the free and the
home of the brave and that is why we
will beat this thing together